[Musica]
e vero che ci sono dei tipi di
fallimenti che ci aiutano a crescere a
diventare persone migliori più mature ma
ce ne sono altri che semplicemente
sarebbe meglio evitare se non altro per
gli effetti devastanti che possono
comportare il mio dipartimento si può
dire il mio laboratorio che si occupo di
questo secondo tipo di fallimenti ovvero
di sviluppare soluzioni tecnologiche che
ci aiutano a evitare queste
configurazioni le applicazioni di
interesse sono le più numerose le più
svariate soprattutto ramo auto motive
automazione industriale ambiti molto
importanti per la nostra zona
l'avionica il biomedicale la difesa e
via dicendo
in gergo si chiamano sistemi di tempo
reale safety critical ovvero sono i
sistemi che semplicemente non possono
fallire devono sempre computare
risultato corretto e tale risultato
corretto va computato entro ben
determinate tempistiche spesso dopo aver
funzionato per anni ultimamente abbiamo
deciso di approfondire
forse il più interessante di questi
settori
sicuramente il più complesso è il più
pericoloso quello dell'auto moti un
milione e 300 mila sono i morti ogni
anno nelle nostre strade ordini di
grandezza più alti il numero di feriti
tenete conto che in questo momento c'è
più o meno un miliardo di automobili nel
mondo fatto un rapido calcolo viene
fuori un fattore di rischio superiore
all'uno per cento
ecco immaginate adesso di essere in un
mondo di stop in un universo parallelo
dove domani uno di noi inventa
l'automobile
secondo voi quale il paese quale governo
considerebbe permetterebbe di mettere in
commercio un prodotto con una simile
fattore di rischio e non solo è anche il
prodotto più complesso tra quelli che ho
menzionato almeno dal punto di vista
informatico
vedete che alcuni sistemi che
intuitivamente potrebbero sembrare più
complessi
lo space shuttle ha più o meno mezzo
milione di linee di codice un aereo di
linea attuale arriva a dieci volte tanto
più o meno 5 milioni di linee di codice
un'enormità
ebbene una macchina di alta fascia che
compriamo oggi un numero di linee di
codice più o meno sui 100 milioni fino a
300 milioni per non parlare del numero
di processori di wiring di cavi di
connessioni tra i vari componenti
elettronici
se mettessimo insieme tutte queste
connessioni arriveremo più o meno tra i
3 ei 4 km sono numeri impressionanti il
numero di controllori di processori
quando ero piccolo io non ce n'erano
sembra forse 12 per i componenti di base
ora sono sul centinaio e continuano
evolvere ormai il costo dell'elettronica
in un veicolo ha raggiunto più o meno
insieme alla validazione del testing il
50 per cento del costo di tutto il
veicolo
l'ottanta per cento nei veicoli a
trazione elettrica
solo che questi sistemi sono solo in
minima parte responsabili delle morti di
cui ho detto prima è vero sono stati
responsabili di campagne di ritiro di
massa che hanno avuto grandi impatti sul
web sui costruttori di auto motive
ma il responsabile principale è un altro
e lo vedete lì siamo noi
l'aci in una calcolo recente che ha
fatto ha stimato che tre su quattro
degli incidenti fatali sulle nostre
strade sono dovuti alla distrazione
dell'uomo lo sappiamo bene chi di noi
non ha avuto colpi di sonno non ha
resistito alla tentazione di di
controllare il cellulare mentre alla
guida
ebbene cosa può fare la tecnologia in
tal senso ci può aiutare
si può sostituire noi in qualche caso le
compagnie con cui lavoriamo chiamano
questi sistemi guardian angel angeli
custodi
proprio perché intervengono quando si
accorgono che c'è un momento di pericolo
che il guidatore non è all'altezza della
situazione e o lo avvisano o addirittura
prendono il controllo di questa macchina
stiamo parlando già delle condizioni che
porteranno alle macchine che si guidano
da sole scenari fantascientifici quando
parlo con i miei amici sembra non mi
credono quando gli dico che fra poco le
avremo tra noi effettivamente già negli
anni 50 si preconizzava arrivo di tali
macchine qui vedete un commercio e non a
una pubblicità di quegli anni in questo
in particolare di una compagnia
elettrica statunitense dove si dava per
imminente l'arrivo di queste automobili
in questo caso attraverso dispositivi
integrati nella strada
ecco 70 anni dopo non abbiamo niente di
questo genere sulle strade
io dico che invece adesso stavolta siamo
siamo proprio vicini ad averli il motivo
è sostanzialmente tecnologico e tutti i
più grandi produttori di hardware dei
sistemi che vanno sui vostri elector i
vostri personal computer
ecco tutti loro stanno sviluppando i
processori di alta fascia specificamente
per il mercato automotive sono
processori che sono ordini di grandezza
più potenti di quelli seppur complessi
che attualmente abbiamo sui nostri
dispositivi si dice tant'è vero che la
macchina sarà il computer più potente
che avremo nel prossimo futuro
immaginate tutte le applicazioni che
questa potenza di calcolo potrebbe
comportare personalmente sarei molto
contento di spendere in maniera molto
più utile le due ore che passo ogni
giorno da mantova dove abito venire qua
modena o anche solo per riposare
sono convinto che certe problemi critici
come il traffico e la ricerca di
parcheggio sarebbero significativamente
migliorati pensiamo ad esempio una
macchina autonoma che ci accompagna nel
punto dove vogliamo andare
e poi si va a parcheggiare da solo
altrove può sembrare uno scenario
veramente fantascientifico ma sono
disposto a scommettere con chi vuole che
entro dieci anni questi sistemi di
vedremo sulle strade
probabilmente molto meno si tratta
quindi di applicazioni che tuttora non
possiamo neanche prevedere immaginate a
tutto il lavoro che stanno facendo in
google in huber sul car sharing è una
rivoluzione è una vera e propria
rivoluzione
che non coinvolge solo il mondo
dell'auto morti ma tutta una serie di
settori e che sono convinto che si
espanderà molto rapidamente
così come si è diffuso rapidamente le
tecnologie di smartphone telefonini per
cui siamo passati in dieci anni da non
sapere cosa fossero
ma non poterne proprio fare a meno la
macchina sarà il primo sistema di
intelligenza artificiale capillarmente
diffuso sul territorio
isaac asimov uno dei più grandi padri
della letteratura di fantascienza nonchè
inventore delle leggi della robotica
non so se avrebbe immaginato che i primi
robot in mezzo a noi fossero su quattro
ruote
sicuramente c'è ancora molto da fare
lo sappiamo in ambito di sicurezza
ci sono diverse tecnologie che stiamo
aiutando sviluppare a migliorare ma la
macchina l'intelligenza artificiale ha
di per sé dei vantaggi competitivi
rispetto all'uomo che vale sicuramente
la pena di considerare pensiamo al tempo
di reazione
l'uomo tra il riconoscere un ostacolo
decidere che deve frenare e attuare la
frenata più o meno passa un secondo
secondo gli studi un secondo in
autostrada facciamo più o meno 35 metri
da qua a oltre alla fine del teatro è
una macchina attraverso gli algoritmi
che si stanno sviluppando permetterà di
farlo entro pochi millisecondi e
soprattutto parlando anche alle altre
macchine che sono in giro al supporto
infrastrutturale che potremmo avere per
identificare anche altri ostacoli che
sono fuori dal nostro orizzonte di vista
ma il vantaggio principale è proprio che
vedere col fallimento quando l'uomo
fallisce in questi casi e purtroppo non
lo può raccontare
oppure semplicemente non può trasferire
l'esperienza maturata pienamente agli
altri individui gli altri guidatori
ecco non è il caso dell'intelligenza
artificiale siamo su alcuni progetti
europei dove si sta cercando di
collezionare gli scenari critici e gli
scenari di incidente
attraverso i quali poi gli algoritmi di
guida autonoma verranno migliorati
le tecniche attualmente utilizzate per
fare questi autopilota sostanzialmente
sono tecniche di machine learning che
imparano attraverso l'errore quindi
hanno bisogno di casi di errore per
migliorare per evitare di riconnettere
lo stesso errore
ecco che si crea una sorta di
intelligenza distribuita che pian piano
evolve attraverso un'esperienza fino a
diventare anche più sicura di quanto sia
una macchina oggi guidata dall'uomo
permettetemi di concludere ancora una
volta riportando l'attenzione a questa
rivoluzione che non sarà solo una
rivoluzione nel mondo dei trasporti ma
coinvolgerà tutta una serie di
professioni che adesso magari pensiamo
immuni anche professioni intellettuali
avrà impatti sociali economici che
assolutamente necessario valutare e
farlo adesso
diciamo che non è una rivoluzione cui ci
possiamo opporre perché accadrà comunque
ma la rivoluzione che va compresa
anticipata e accompagnata mettendo al
centro sempre l'uomo di modo che non sia
l'uomo al servizio della tecnologia ma
la tecnologia rimanga al servizio
dell'uomo
non farlo sarebbe probabilmente il
nostro più grande errore
grazie
[Applauso]